monsieur x nette courte au beach bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur rt france alors on sait que le 4
novembre 2010 huit ans les électeurs
calédonien avait voté en faveur du
maintien au sein de la république
française
est-ce que la situation a évolué depuis
la première consultation au point
justement elle d'effacer l'écart entre
les partisans du oui et ceux du nom
c'est justement la question est ce que
ce deuxième référendum sera spécifique
où il ressemblera au premier c'est à
dire eux
est ce que finalement le partisan du non
où les partisans du oui feront un
secours très différent du premier
référendum
ce qui obligera les partis politiques à
considérer ce deuxième comme ayant un
intérêt propre ayant une réponse propres
on vient de parler de la crise du nickel
est la principale richesse de l'île
quels sont les autres enjeux justement
de ce référendum sur l'indépendance
l'enjeu principal c'est quand même le
lien constitutionnel avec la république
française le nickel est passé latéral
dont la problématique du vote parce que
nous avons la compétence sur sur les
mines et l'état nous assistent que par
l'économie sur les mines on est dans les
projets en défiscalisant etc
mais nous avons la compétence minière si
vous voulez le principal c'est le lien
constitutionnel avec la france puisque
au terme de l'accord de nouméa
le référendum porte sur la
transformation de la citoyenneté de la
nouvelle calédonie en nationalité et sur
le transfert des compétences régaliennes
en sommes aux nouveaux pays crée donc
cesser cette question constitutionnelle
avec toutes ses conséquences notamment
économiques qui cristallise le le débat
chez nous quoi on sait que à midi le
taux de participation
été est assez élevé on parle
je vous donne l'estimation exacte plus
de 49 % c'est-à-dire 8% plus que lors du
premier référendum c'est un bon signe
selon vous oui très bon signe parce
qu'évidemment plus il y a deux
participations plus le résultat est
enraciné démocratiquement parlant donc
vous savez la nouvelle calédonie est une
collectivité qui est divisé en trois
provinces c'est comme une collectivité
fédéral en somme et autant dans la
province nord il y avait une
participation massive en 2018 qui est
difficilement dépassables autant en
province sud notamment dans la ville de
nouméa et dans l'agglomération
la participation avait été un petit peu
en dessous de celle ce qu'elle aurait pu
être comparées à la province nord par
contre pour la province des îles
la participation avait été plus faible
pour des raisons spécifiques et
politique en somme
donc cela dit on s'attend d'après ce
qu'on entend là dans la journée là on
est quatre heures de l'après-midi en
nouvelle calédonie on s'attend à une
augmentation un peu général ou en tout
cas à une participation égale là où elle
était déjà très fort si jamais le nom
l'emportent dernier scrutin
devrait avoir lieu d'ici fin 2021 début
2022 c'est en tout cas ce qui est prévu
dans l'accord de nouméa
quelles sont les tendances est-ce que
voilà vous pensez qu'on aura besoin
justement d'une troisième concertation
pour pouvoir savoir l'avenir connaître
l'avenir de l'archipel
c'est ce que je vous disais en début de
cet entretien ça va dépendre de la
nouveauté des résultats de ce deuxième
référendum
toutefois le texte de l'accord de nouméa
qui a été conclue il ya plus de vingt
ans maintenant prévoit un troisième
référendum à la demande de nos élus au
bout de six mois en toute hypothèse donc
ensemble ce ça dépend de l'analyse que
feront les indépendantistes les non
indépendantistes et de ce scrutin mais
ils ont la possibilité d'un troisième
référendum et personne n'y peut rien
c'est dans le contrat qui a été approuvé
au moment du référendum sur l'accord de
nouméa
dernière question à monsieur il se met
courteau vite comment s'est organisée
justement la campagne du oui et du non
avant ce référendum
et bien c'est organisé en somme comme
toutes les élections en nouvelle
calédonie on a beaucoup d'élections et
donc il y à eu un suivi très rigoureux
de la part de l'état et aussi des pays
de la région et de l'onu sur l'ensemble
de son déroulement
et aussi la mise au point des listes
électorales nécessité des discussions
politiques approfondie parce qu'on
s'était aperçu qu'il y avait des hiatus
dans dans le nombre de personnes
susceptibles de voter et qui ne
pouvaient inscrits automatiquement ou
pas les personnes ici nous avons deux
statues civile en nouvelle calédonie le
statut coutumier le statut de droit
commun donc tout ça a nécessité des
négociations qui ont été réglés avec le
premier référendum mais au deuxième il
ya eu encore des ajustements
hélas la campagne s'est déroulée dans
les formes démocratiques traditionnels
avec des innovations avec les nouvelles
technologies mais en somme elle elle
s'est déroulée au rythme de on pourrait
dire la démocratie calédonienne de façon
satisfaisante au plan démocratique si je
pourrais dire très bien en tout cas
merci beaucoup monsieur il se mettre
courteau beach d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
historien et spécialiste de la nouvelle
calédonie contemporaine